Nói bằng một nằm nắm nằm của trọng hay bì sống.
Sự kiện khách trường các hộ bẩu diễn án thì emerald bú lề vá
tại Sels Gallery tập đoàn liên phong, phương lấy điều thật buổi chi Minh,
tụi búc sử quang tâm rất lớn của đồng đạo quyết thẳng,
các đối tác và chuyên biên tìm bấn giữ án.
Ngay từ những bước trân đự kiếm vào cú vực nhả bẩu,
khách thăm quan đã được dân dắc vào một hành trình trái gì khó quyền,
cung khoảng hấp ứng cường khi chạm đến trường sống tỉ nghi đàn cấp đại các hộ
di emerald bú lề vá ở đó, không giang án sẵn bố cục và tí kế đội thức đồng giáo
thuò, nơi mỗi mẹc buồn đều được tí kế để mà lại giả trị sống trong vẻng cho cho cho
cho cho.
Dí emerald bú lề vá là giữa án thật tác cung xanh xung,
chính khai hệ sinh thái sạch phing, đồng bộ trong không giang cáng bộ.
Thông qua một linh bản kích nối quy nhất, kuy trên có thể giả dạng điều khiến
tìm địa tìm địa và hệ tống tâm bên ngay trên địa trải,
yếu điều quà, máy dật, hề các kịch bản sinh hoặc hành ngày,
công nghệ không chỉ dừng ở yếu tố tỉ nghi mà còn hướng đến cá nhân quá trả nghiệm sống,
đối yêu bật hành và nâng cơ chắc lượng ăn cơ chạy hạn.
Lên cảnh công nghệ di emerald bú lề vá còn tạo giấu án thí bộ hình căng hộ thế hệ vá,
dù hướng thích kế mới, đe cao trả nghiệm sống thật và khả năng trích nối với thình dình.
Nếu các dòng cán hộ trước đây thường tùng tài nhiều khương dạc kinh,
hạc kẻ sáng bà đối lưu khương ký,
thì tài đi emerald bú lề vá,
toàn bộ khương dàng chính dư phòng cách phòng vũ vá khu sinh hoặc,
đều được tiếp sức chực tiếp bối mặt tháng kỳ yên,
dàng tối yêu an sáng tâm dình và đủ khi lưu thông,
lời ra cũng được sự lý theo hướng tắt chiên và đưa vào trong để tăng tính tâm Mỹ,
hạng chế diễn mù thì giác và giữ sự thân thách cho tổng thể cán hộ.
Sông hành cùng thiết kế gì gài là tiếp dẫn bàn giao thung hành tình tâm bộ với hệ thiết bị và vật liệu
cao cấp trường cút kế, giúp kêu dân có thể biêu các ngộ vào sĩ dùng nế sốt yên dịch nhạc.
Thì cũng đất hài lòng về kế giả kế, mốt cuộc mơ,
mốt chí thì thì cũng hài hòa.
Hủng đàn hàm khả hó khăn mà vầm nấu,
mình cũng được biết là ở đây để cũng sẽ có tập tuy xem dân,
cho không dân cân, hả là có có phục dân dân dân,
cho không dân cân, đất hả khi cũng có tùng tham thức mạnh kế thì muốn là cho
bếc quý tần với dài nó có trở để nó giả.
Dạ, mạnh kế giả lòng về kế giả.
VHG là đẹp mắt biệt.
Mặc tiền của gồm mời bá, mừng tiền gái thì nó sẽ có đến sau điện.
Đừng sáng, cũng sẽ hát tăng tiền không khóc.
Mấy chế nữa.
Mấy chế.
Về thịt kế.
Cái gì có thể nói?
Hai hình đại
Thịp Tế thì nói
Thống khó
Để cái là
Bất công nè
Vất là dài
Chúng mình sẽ nói mọi thứ
Cái này là chút hay cũng
Hồi ngồi giải chút hồ dật có rồi
Thì chút thấy đất ok
Chua đường sau sáng
Cái hay không như cái mà không
Chút thế nào
Tốt sẽ quất đại
Đi em bờ đồ của Li Ba
Chứ hữu lệ thể cảnh quan khi là bục trong xúc et chự án
Thì là thiên của lộ Mui Ba
có bị chi tiếp chắc gần nhất với xong sẽ còn màu quan bệ hệ thống xung nước cùng rặt bánh bình
dãng với ra bị tế tử dịn hướng trủy với tình dình dọng về chúng tâm thần bầu chi Minh
mà đến bôi trường sống khoảng đặt.
Dự án liên kê bình tìu của tế hạnh phúc, gá từ bên phức, khu rô thị bản phúc,
cũng hát loa tỉ nhất ngoại khu hị rữ, tư dự án đi emerala bolê ba,
cười dân gị trị nhằm chấm và thục lời đến gá thương hạnh cân chỉ từ buì lắm phúc,
đến chúng tâm thần bầu chi Minh phương xe gòn chỉ từ 2 biệt phúc
và đến sự bài phúc tế từ xung nhất chỉ từ 2 milan phúc.
Trong với cảnh quyết dất pè sông ngày càng khăn đến,
các dự án sở hụi tố mặt nước mạnh cân,
cùng tránh giị sống tuông bên và tí chợ mặt dạo cao cấp,
tìm nhất chuẩn bị sọt như di emerala bolê ba,
đàn dân trở thành lợp đả chị khách miệng của phần cúc căng hồ cao cấp gì đây.
Dí emerala bolê ba, sống trọng tình lợp tin xong.